hi all right well so it has to talk
about cover crops i heard the nice segue
into that with a discussion at the end
there there's some particular
opportunities for using cover crops in
the reduced tillage system so hang on a
second I need to fire mine up to go
along so I'm just going to say next
slide when we switch slides or whoever's
controlling the main display so we'll go
to the next slide so that some of the
main reasons you use cover crops in
general is to have covered during
periods of erosion the wind and water
erosion on Long Island was up just a
moment ago and that's a good example
they're good at suppressing weeds during
seasons when weeds grow eagerly tilth
improvement is a really big reason why
people use it and also for suppression
of soil borne pests and of these one
that plays the biggest role I think for
reduced tillage is for tilt improvement
because the cover crops are doing some
of the work that you would normally do
with your tillage equipment so on the
next slide I've drawn a picture of the
reduced tillage situation so this is in
my little diagram you've got undisturbed
soil and then in the lighter brown
that's your slot right so this is
looking from the from the side
underground I work a lot on route so
putting the root surface at the top of
the slide is normal for me but it may
take a moment to adjust to that so for
erosion protection you want sometimes
cover crops that give you a light
residue on the surface of the soil
you're just talking about the heavy
residue of rye but having a light
residue is something that can be very
useful because you're driving on it all
the time it's helpful to have
a matrix that holds the soil together so
that it supports your equipment better
without compacting so that's one
important role that cover crops can play
you're just talking about the question
of having that the slot close up enough
but not too much and with the heavier
soil that sometimes the fall is the
right time but if you're on a sandy soil
you really have to prepare it in the
spring because it's not going to stay
open very long so you have a lot of
considerations that you're taking into
account to manage that slot so when you
plant it's in the right shape for your
seats to take off and for situations
where you're preparing in the fall you
may be getting that slot prepared but
you have the opportunity to have a lot
of erosion and consolidation happen in
the slot and then it's not really where
you want it to be in the spring so
there's a role for cover crops in
overwinter slot management as you go
deeper in the soil if you get compaction
and then evitable you get deep
compaction because conditions aren't
always perfect when you drive there that
you need to make holes basically and
cover crop roots can do that for you
since you're not going to put a shank
down in the other parts of the field you
can use cover crops to do that and
finally it's useful to get nitrogen down
in the rest of the soil zone as well and
to some extent cover crops can help you
do that so your crop roots have more
places to go looking for their
fertilizer so I'll talk through those
how to do that and on the next one as
you're looking for a light surface
residue you want to somewhat mature
tissue if it's really green it will
break down right away and and won't last
and you want to moderate biomass so
again the discussion just before on on
the Rye where you have a high biomass
there are a lot of questions about the
the challenges of dealing with that if
they get detached or aim in different
directions
or keep the ground too wet or too cold
or post slugs or all kinds of
interesting things that you might need
to deal with if you have heavy biomass
you have moderate biomass those are much
smaller issues and the candidates for
doing that is a small grain but in that
case killed relatively small so not
letting it go to heading stage at all
but maybe eight or ten inches tall and
another one is annual rye grass that's
planted in a somewhat different season
it doesn't take off on you the way a
small grain can and it makes for a finer
biomass material it doesn't last as long
once you've killed it so the next goal
the matrix for support so the
characteristics you want to have that
matrix to really make it a network that
holds the soil particles together you
want a lot of rooting near the surface
and you want those roots to be pretty
tough after they're dead and so strong
Reuters so turf grasses are a great
example of this this is one of the
reasons you have dressed driveways and
alleys and that sort of thing so annual
rye grass is the cover crop that is the
most turf like that establishes quickly
it can be used in in that system the
small grains do it not quite as well but
they're easier to establish so there may
be an opportunity there and Sudan grass
does the dense rooting near the surface
and has really tough roots when it's
dead the challenge that you might have
the reason for the question mark is that
they also have pretty substantial crowns
and that may be too big for other
operations that you're doing in that
system so that may or may not work it
certainly will provide a good matrix and
pretty tough roots
so moving on to the next management goal
relieving compaction the first quality
of course at the cover crop has that is
that it tolerates that compaction that
it will grow through the compacted soil
and actually put holes in it it also
needs to naturally go deep so something
like the annual ryegrass that's making a
dense root mass near the surface is
completely useless for this purpose you
want something that wants to go down no
matter what wants to keep going down
down down so that it penetrates the plow
pan in many places so you want actually
a lot of roots that are going deep so it
makes many holes and you need them to be
pretty thick so that if a really fine
root goes through it doesn't do you a
lot of good you want enough space that
an earthworm can sneak through the
powder can drip through the air can go
through and that crop roots and that
you're growing next can go through so by
thick roots something on the order of a
tenth of an inch or maybe even a little
bit smaller than that is just fine so
they don't need to be two inches you
don't need to hold that big so there's
there's more options so you see the
candidates number one radish that's the
obviously the two incher if you've seen
any of the abundant press that tillage
radishes have gotten in the last year or
so they make gigantic holes at the top
and they make smaller holes at the
bottom and they are very good at going
down deep but there are some other
things that you may find as attractive
or even more attractive forage turnips
once you're down where that plow pan
would typically be their roots are about
the same diameter as radishes so even
though they don't make the same big hole
at the top if you're interested in how
many holes are they actually making in
the plow pen they're going to be
competitive with the radish and they're
going to grow longer into the fall and
mustards are very easy to use and they
also do a good job
the roots aren't quite as thick that
they're also very determined to go deep
so in the next slide managing that slot
so this is something that you would
plant you would be making that slot in
the fall you're concerned that that slot
needs some protection in order to be in
the right condition in the springtime
and for that you need something that
winter kills fairly late in the winter
so that it's holding the soil together
as long as possible but you want those
roots to be pretty succulent so unlike
the matrix you want these to decompose
quickly because you're not trying to
hold that slot together you're trying to
turn it into a seedbed you're trying to
run the planter through there you don't
want to be having to cut through a lot
of tough roots so you want those to
decompose by the time you plant so here
again I've put radishes the first
candidate and it's very good at
decomposing it'll be completely gone by
planting time in the spring it doesn't
do so well in the winter killing late
it's the first of the crucifer cover
crops to die in the in the winter it's
part of the reason it's so well be
composed by the spring so that's a
trade-off but it may not be holding the
shallow part of the slot as well as some
of the others and so I've put turnip and
rapeseed in here they're really fairly
comparable relatively inexpensive if you
go to a supplier of forage seed and
they're going to winter kill about this
time of year in fact today was probably
pretty hard on them but if they die now
they're kept in the freezer and stay
nice and green until the snow is gone
temperatures get up closer to freezing
and then they decompose and you'll have
had the soil held together
a lot longer through the through the
winter and into the spring and they may
keep the slot soil in a better condition
they're in all of these cases this
should be dead and gone and decomposed
and you should just have nice soil by
the time you go to plant in that slot so
then on the next slide we'll think about
how do you sneak some nitrogen into that
untilled soil using the cover crop so in
terms of qualities it doesn't really
matter to you whether they're fixing
nitrogen or scavenging nitrogen that has
gone deep below the root zone or is left
behind after your previous crop those
are both perfectly fine ways to get the
nitrogen and to put it in the form of
organic nitrogen that's going to become
mineralized for the crop during the year
so in this winter killing late is
actually quite important because if you
have something like the radish that dies
in December when you get the snowmelt a
lot of that is this going to flush on
through it will decomposed into soluble
nitrogen forms already by the time that
happens so you do want winter killing
later in the season so the nitrogen is
still there but you still want it to
decompose well you're not interested in
having it be nitrogen for next year you
want it to be nitrogen this year so the
first candidate here is a nitrogen fixer
the hairy vetch hairy vetch does just
about all of its nitrogen fixing in May
once it starts to flower you get a
decline in the nitrogen-fixing so really
the timing for controlling hairy vetch
is a pretty narrow window at the end of
May but it will have nitrogen not only
in the abundant tops but it will have
been sending nitrogen to the roots and
its really the nitrogen in the roots
that's going to be the big supply so
killing the hairy vetch very early in
its flowering is the stage that would
let you put vetch root nitrogen into the
untilled parts of the soil and then
going with the nitrogen scavengers that
will be dying if the right time
of your are again the turnip and the
rape scene and being cole crops they're
heavy feeders they're going to suck up
any nitrogen that's sitting around in
the soil available for bleaching or
crops but they also end up being quite
succulent and so they will decompose
they'll have roots throughout that until
layer like we saw in the previous couple
of slides they'll penetrate the untilled
part just fine they have tough roots for
doing that and so the nitrogen that is
in those roots will remain in the soil
and we'll be having a supply of nitrogen
and a reason for your crop roots to be
rummaging around in that untilled layer
that you've been working hard to
establish good tilth in so I want to
move on to how you manage these cover
crops i basically identified the
selection of the cover crops but
thinking of how you manage them too much
special about the reduced tillage system
so there's really two steps in
management that we want to be concerned
about how do you establish the cover
crop well without tillage and how do you
kill it so i'll start with the
establishment on the next slide
obviously it's harder to get the seed
into ground that you haven't tilt or
that you've you may have prepared a slot
but you really did that for the crop
next year so it's not in ideal
conditions when you're looking at the
cover crop in the late summer or fall so
getting the getting something that will
have those seeds make good soil contact
and ind absorb water is the question so
the no-till drill very heavy expensive
piece of equipment you need to have
ideal soil conditions before you want to
bring something that big on to the
ground but they do a perfectly fine job
of putting particularly things like
small grains or should andres in the
ground frost seeding is something that
you can't do every year but it can
actually work pretty nicely
with mustard would be the one of these
and that's if you're going to have the
cover crop in there just for a short
time in the early spring if you're
planting later in the late May June with
those when you you need bare ground or
just a little bit of life recent snow on
top and that you'll have a number of
freeze-thaw cycles it's the freeze-thaw
cycles basically you get fairly large
ice crystals forming in the top making a
hole in the soil when that ice melts you
get a mustard seed sized hole left
behind where it melted and the mustard
seed drops down that's basically the
process that makes frost seeding work
and it works on bare ground or if you
have very very slight residue on the
ground that can work even if you haven't
tilled it so it's a fairly specialized
situation but that's something that can
be done and then what I've called
surface tailored so the airway is
probably the most common tool to do this
but in essence you're making little
slots in the surface you're not telling
it's just very very superficial but
making little slots so that you can come
through with a oftentimes spinning on it
makes a little place where that seed can
land and have seen soil contact and with
that one combining that with a manure
application really improves
establishment of the cover crop and
provide some nitrogen for your next
year's crop also the cover crop will
help hold that manure nitrogen I where
it's going to be crop available on the
next slide we'll look at killing the
cover crop so by and large you want to
kill the grasses with an herbicide most
of them are not going to be dying from
winter kill that you need an herbicide
to get them dead at the
they need to be starting to decompose
with many of these if you go early a
superficial disking so it's not an
airway but the challenge with that is
when you're going shallow and cutting it
across it's easy to get survivors you
have to kill all of them you don't have
to go deep usually to kill them but you
do have to get all of them so it's not
that it's not easy to pull off but for
certain situations that's the way to go
and winter kill with the crucifer zai
talked about or with sorghum Sudan grass
works great have having the cover crops
winter hardiness match the typical
winters at your location is the main
thing you have to do so for instance the
dwarf x.x rapeseed overwinters fine and
southeast Pennsylvania Long Island it
does not over winter here so how you how
you would Matt choose the right variety
for your location is actually quite
important for getting that to work but
if you do that right it works great and
then mowing room rolling you were just
discussing I'm not going to say too much
about that having things diet well for
both of those to my mind you're looking
at very late plantings if you're waiting
until they're big enough to be killed by
mowing and rolling that's the biggest
drawback of those as you're looking
pretty late in the season but those are
with small grains and with the vetch the
hairy vetch those are techniques that
are fairly widely used people have
figured out how to get it to work in
their system so with the next slide I'm
going to talk a little bit about these
specific cover crops a bit more so with
the yellow mustard the spring seated
situation I told you about the frost
seeding of that that is definitely the
way
to do it you can use a grass cedar to
get it in by mid-april but if you can
get it frost seated you'll get a lot
more biomass and the time to kill it is
bright as its flowering that's when you
get the biggest weed suppression
benefits that's how you avoid having
mustard become a weed in your field and
with this one herbicide is way better
cultivation mowing you have too many
survivors and the volunteer mustard get
to be a problem so with this spring
situation an herbicide application is
really in order so yellow mustard can
also be used in the fall and that's the
situation we're using any airway and
manure you can even mix this the mustard
seed in the manure if you have a tank
that's agitated you just dump the seed
in that the rate you've calculated and
it goes with the manure hits the slots
that the airway created and you get a
really nice stand and there's lots of
nitrogen for the mustard to grow and you
get a biomass it's really very nice
we're talking about a late August event
here in general yellow mustard bolts you
can see the tall plants on the right
there once they've bolted they reliably
winterkill with the late August planting
date they'll flower in the fall but by
the time they flower in October it's too
late for them to make seat so that
actually ends up working nicely you
don't have the volunteer problem those
stems end up holding the snow so you see
the snow in the picture there for those
stems are that's a picture in December
so the leaves are still on them those
are completely decomposed it's just tan
stocks in the spring but they will
continue to hold snow into the spring
but the residue is very brittle so once
you get out in the field those go right
over it's not like dealing with right
to do at all next are its relative
turnip and rapeseed they're they're
really quite the forward forms are
closely related the difference is that
the turnips make about a two inch turnip
and the rapeseed starts to both the
little mate and makes maybe a six or
eight inches stem both of those events
are what makes them susceptible to
winter killing they have tough fruit
that's what's really nice about this
they go deep they pull up a lot of
nitrogen and so you get your your
compaction relief but then you get a lot
of decomposition so in the lower
right-hand corner there you see a little
network of stuff that is early April
that's what it looks like in early April
there's really very minimal residue with
these when they've winter killed and so
the ground is starting to show clearly
so you don't have to worry about
nitrogen or excuse me worried about
having too much residue if you need the
ground to dry to warm up in the Sun
that's going to happen just fine you get
some suppression of the spring
germinating cool-season annual weeds
which is nice but it may not be a real
big benefit those are often easily
controlled by other means to but if
that's useful to you that's often one of
the outcomes the next one is the big
star of 2010 tillage radish so on the
left there those are the big radishes
sticking out of the ground it's a lot of
fun to go see those on the right is more
typically what you would see in a field
where you've planted radish they're
planted at a fairly low density you can
actually see a few spots of soil
sticking through there and you want that
you want the plants to be bid you want
them to go deep you don't want a lot of
little ones and if you plant it to high
density you even get a lot of
suppression that if you plant twice
many you don't get twice the weight you
don't even get the same way you get less
weight produced by these and they end up
shallow so you want a fairly low seeding
rate on the tillers radishes to get them
to do their thing so good nitrogen
scavengers real early winter killers so
again places like Long Island that may
work out perfectly but if you're looking
at cooler areas of New York and Vermont
probably even Western Massachusetts then
they're going to be dying quite early
and the next one finally I'll or not the
last one but switching to the legend
hairy vetch so in my scheme of cover
crops this is when you need nitrogen
fixation and you're sewing in the fall
this is the one you go with it really
needs to have some sort of a nurse crop
to do well and oats is a probably the
most popular candidate for that because
it the oats will winter kill and you
only end up with the Bech in the
springtime if you're looking for a lot
of nitrogen it's a good companion with
rye but then why is the main crop it's
that's not for growing hairy vetch
that's for making the ride decomposed so
really a nurse crop would be something
like oats to get it going you would kill
it in late May so if that's too late for
you that would be a problem there's two
new varieties out that came out of USDA
led breeding program Cornell was
involved with these called purple bounty
and purple prosperity they give you a
week or 10 days earlier bloom so you can
kill them then that's very helpful if
you raise small grain crops hairy vetch
has hard seed that seed will germinate
in subsequent years so you'll have hairy
vetch coming back with smaller grains
they will make those volunteers will
make seed exactly the same size as wheat
at exactly the same time as wheat and
it's very hard to clean it out and the
mills don't like it so they'll reject
your crop so you don't want to set
yourself up for that so that's
the warning then on the next is annual
ryegrass so annual ryegrass is one that
broadcasts very well it's a small grass
seed but it will take broadcast on the
surface in many conditions and really
any time there's moisture on the soil it
will go but usually in august early
September it works really nicely you
have to be you have to kill it in the
spring so it doesn't go to seed or
continue to grow in your crop and that
can be a little bit tricky to be
susceptible to glyphosate it needs to be
growing pretty well so that it's moving
the glyphosate around the plant that's
not living off the reserves and just
making more leaves because I'm the
glyphosate doesn't really end up where
it needs to go to kill the thing so you
have to wait until it's it's the air is
warmed up in the crop the cover crop has
started to grow before the glyphosate
will really take and it may take a
couple of shots to get it to die so
survival reseeding if it's older the
ground it's a little bit clumpy because
of the Crown's that's a those clumps are
good in the untilled part of your
reduced tillage system they're not so
good in the slot so you may want to do
some planning there as far as where that
rye grass ends up growing next are the
smaller grains I've already said some
things about those so the oats will
winter kill so they give you that nice
light residue on the surface from a fall
crop the Rye is really forgiving as far
as the conditions and timing of planting
in the fall but in the spring it can get
away from you so unless you really know
what you're doing with the tall Roy crop
and know how to handle all that material
and find your slides and get the crop
planted in it and have the ground warm
up some people do that very well if you
don't know how to do that four to six
inches tall just that you see that mat
in the bottom half of the picture there
that's what it looks like before it
starts to grow that'll turn green and
hop up very quickly and that's about the
time you would want to be hitting it
with an herbicide to stop it growing and
leave the residue and let the roots
decompose and then you can come in and
use that as a nice base for planting
into the slot so to summarize how do you
decide what you're going to do first of
all you you need to know what you're
trying to accomplish and went through a
number of different things that you may
need in in a particular season for your
reduced tillage to work better so when
you know what what you want to do find
what in general the candidates are that
might do that thing then you need to
think about the constraints of using
that particular cover crop so if you're
growing a lot of cabbage and broccoli
you probably are not that interested in
radishes and turnips so there you'll you
may not be able to plant some of these
cover crops with the equipment that you
have so you select an appropriate cover
crops given given those constraints so
that's the process I would go through to
to the side and on the final slide the
website cover crop net is where I have
information including a selection tool
that will help you go through that
decision process and you don't have to
look things up all over the place it
compiled all that all the information
you need to make those decisions in one
place and even put things side by side
so thanks very much i'm happy to take
some questions thomas on is here i'm
gonna look in ithaca anyone has any
question
for Thomas nope all right how about in
Massachusetts anybody have questions
with Thomas nope wait Thomas what did
you consider a low seeding rate for the
tillage radish now so that with the
tillage radish seven or eight pounds so
the the seed salesman sometimes
recommend higher rates than that some of
the literature does but in recent work
going down to seven pounds has given
only benefits and no disadvantages great
how about out in western New York Carol
tell us about your ryegrass straight
with her back so I don't know the answer
to that question it's a good question
and I think we don't know what that when
that's acceptable and how much Oh Thomas
could you repeat the question I don't
know we can oh sorry the co the question
was using remarks on to kill annual
ryegrass so somebody in somebody with
experience might might actually know
that appear one comment is that you need
nitrogen in the soil in order to get
those crucifer 'he's to grow really well
that is certainly true the so if you're
coming in after something that's been
harvested green where you have a lot of
residual nitrogen they will often do
fine on the residual nitrogen but if
you've harvested a crop that's contra
maturity and you no longer have residual
nitrogen in the soil they will take some
nitrogen to get them going we found that
we get bad growth with none and decent
growth with 25 pounds or so of nitrogen
so it doesn't have to be a lot you don't
have to follow the recommendation
the mustard growers to put on 125 240
pounds of nitrogen not that you're
likely to do that anyway but that's also
the situation where if you're doing
manure applications that's a good
combination on those sorghum Sudan dress
that I only mentioned briefly is another
one that really needs some residual
nitrogen or a little start to get it
going in order to give you what you need
thanks Carol great um how about Jeff
Miller any questions at your location
one of the growers had a question about
what was the question Mike turn up how
early in the fall of the turn up to die
how early in the fall in here will the
turnips die in upstate New York like
Central New York right that if you have
a big turn up the two or three inch
turnip they seem to die in January month
and februari so days like today when we
have particularly cold spells that's
when that turnip itself freezes the
meristem may survive and the the very
small plants may survive a little bit
longer but it's basically right about
now that they're being killed if you
look at them they look fine but they
would look fine if you stuck them in
your freezer too it's after you take
them out that they look bad so there
there are parts of them that are still
alive but the whole plant is going to
die Thomas does the snow cover change
that that timing of death of the plants
well snow covered helps them survive no
question about that so if you have more
snow covered you get more survival
because they're not experiencing the
same amount of cold so you have the
inherent winter hardiness of the plant
as one factor you have how big it is if
it's a rosette still so there's no
swelling of a radish or a turn if
there's no bolting of a mustard or a
rapeseed that's when they're the most
winter hardy give the maximum for that
type of plant whatever its inherent
tardiness is and then you have the
amount of cold
get so a couple of years ago we had a
very warm winter this year it's quite a
bit colder so that varies so there's a
lot of factors that go into exactly when
they die but I think for a lot of
Central New York where you where you
really do get minus 15 that kind of
temperatures in the winter for a long
period with snow cover for short periods
with little snow cover they all of the
ones I mentioned will die by spring all
right how about then questions from Long
Island yes I have one but we planted
right last year and sometimes it seemed
necessary to apply more than one
application of glyphosate to kill it
reliably are there any concerns with
multiple applications of glyphosate
either in the same year or in multiple
years as for subsequent crop growth not
that I know and especially if the if the
Rye is growing well you should be
hitting mostly rye with the spray
material so that will that will be in
the plant and it even though r I will
take up the herbicide at lower
temperatures than a lot of other things
you do still need the greener tissue for
it to be really effective so the picture
I showed where it was the maps of mostly
yellow leaves that had gone through the
winter applying it at that point
probably wouldn't work very well it's
cold and and it's not moving things
around in the plant so just when it
perks up in his green and growing that
it's going to start being sensitive to
it great thanks Tom I've got one more
question from Long Island ok with it
with our leg cross like pumpkins which
is one we want to do a lot of reduced
diligent is there any cover crop you'd
recommend going in and interceding early
on because by the time we're done with
pumpkins it's too late for anything but
why yeah that that is a real good
question we've been playing around with
whether you can use winter canola for
that purpose it stays a rosette longer
than the others that's why we were
interested in that one and we tried
putting it on just as the leaves went
down from powdery mildew but we've been
using gladiator pumpkin and a good spray
program so that hasn't really been
happening until frost so it's really
been too late for them to grow it's been
well into September by the time that
happens sometimes it right at the end of
sep tember but if if the milder is
taking out your pumpkin leaves earlier
that that may work through broadcast as
the leaves go down we also tried
broadcasting so in our situation before
the last cultivation which isn't what
you'd be doing but just before they
start to run when you can still get
through the field to broadcast thinking
that then the leaves cover the the
ground up and so that they won't grow
very much they'll establish and then
they'll sit there and that does happen
the problem we found is that when the
leaves do drop with the frost that they
start to grow pretty well and so by Oh
October 15th and 20th when you may have
a lot of people coming out in your
pumpkin patch they're 68 inches tall and
so it looks very nice having these big
orange egg sitting in the greenery but
that's on the tall side of what you
would want for a good harvest operation
so it's been a little bit tricky to get
those to time right so it's going to be
a very specific where that sort of thing
would work and I haven't tried using
annual rye grass for that purpose but
the same timing putting it on just
or the vines start to run it should
establish just fine but I'm concerned
that after the leaves drop that you can
get too much growth out of that that it
will be too tall for when you're
harvesting if you're picking in early
October and sending it to markets that's
that's obviously less of an issue yeah I
tried the annual rye here annual
ryegrass and it just got way too big by
October it was not it was not good um I
knew can we do we have time for one more
question here on Long Island for Thomas
yeah go ahead and we plant Sargam and
the summer as soon as we feel it's fit
well one of these radishes or other
crops compete with that we chop it two
or three times during the growing season
when the fall planting time comes for
the radish would it compete with that
sorghum if the sorghum was still living
the sorghum slows way down when it gets
cold and becomes pretty uncompetitive so
that was actually fairly early like
mid-september but in our freeville
trials this year is when that transition
happened so add 10 days to that I desk
but the this organ doing the last
chopping of the sorghum you've got the
sorghum Leafs that have been decomposing
from the previous chopping so you should
have a reasonable amount of nitrogen in
the soil from that like mowing it low
that last time and then once the leaves
have broken down enough no tilling
radish seed into that they should do
fine there they're going to grow
vigorously at the temperatures that are
too cold for sorghum so it's a nice
segue there that the temperatures become
bad for sorghum just at the time maybe
so
great for radishes and the nitrogen from
the sorghum becomes available to the
radishes great thanks Thomas and thank
you for joining us